[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars what if
turned out yet another episode leading
us wanting more more more but we are
filling in the pieces with the
mid-season trailer that just came out
some new footage from romanian episodes
seems to be pointing at some kind of
mystery thread on the horizon in the
season finale that the watcher could tie
all of these loose ends back together to
fight who is this multiversal threat and
how close does the watcher need to be to
us to tell us about it because that
breath is
hot
this is rogue theory it's a show where
we pitch the wildest theories to the
nerdy titles we love mt did me a solid
this week by jumping on the easter egg
breakdown freeing me up to come back to
host rogue theory i'm so excited i'm
eric moss and going rogue with me today
we have an amazing panel including good
friend of the show jessica clemens hi
producer and host of the mass effect
adventum podcast matt acevedo hey
everybody
and back from his own astral plane it's
off-screen producer brandon barrick
hello
i'm back baby
guys i'm so excited to talk about where
what it is at right now because assuming
several of these characters from these
past six what if episodes are gonna
return in the finale what threat do we
think they're gonna face and how will it
tie into multiverse of madness because i
think that's the title that this what if
series is most steering toward so are we
going to be looking at a team of fallen
avengers that have to get resurrected
because there was that one shot of
doctor strange with like party thor from
what sounds like an upcoming ragnarok
episode where party thor is like hey
zombies that sounds like a great idea
so are they gonna like resurrect some of
these avengers we've seen die like in
the nick fury episode bringing them back
to life in some crazy way and then we
might see a team of like uh villains
teaming up like killmonger as black
panther as well as ego we know there's a
shot of ego with peter quill catching up
with that episode two post-credits scene
or final scene i should say collector we
might think still be out there zombie
thanos for sure still out there i think
there will be an ultimate big bad that
uh freaks out about and finally
intervenes who do we think that could be
and how do you think that will tie in
the multiverse of madness i kind of
think that doctor strange is gonna be a
bigger deal
you know after that that crazy episode i
really think he's kind of leaning up to
be out for some sort of revenge or
something because uwatu didn't do
anything at all uh to being the watcher
and uh i kind of think you know because
he had the opportunity to just save the
world and he failed to do so i think
he's gonna be out doctor train's going
to be out for like vengeance so i kind
of think we're leading into an original
sin territory where like you know where
owatu is actually going to be the like
it's leading up to owatu dying uh
someone's murdered want to and i think
it's going to be doctor strange and the
original st comic is nick fury who who
takes on the role of uwatu as the
watcher uh i think it's going to be
doctor strange he's going to kill huatu
uh and it's going to lead to some sort
of big multiversal thing um but it's
going to end with i think it's going to
end with steven strange being redeemed
but he's going to become the new watcher
oh that'll be fun also that's like a
hell of itself just becoming the watcher
if you know you have to be who wants to
have to watch everything like that and
then be like i want to
i see all your gross things
it just seems like an eternal loneliness
still i'm just like i can't really
interfere but i can see literally
everything that's happening if you if
you if you're the watcher you have to
come up with all those like pithy
comments and like clever metaphors all
the time
constantly narrating it's it's a really
tough job it's a lot it's a full-time
gig you know they say once he made it to
hosting late night
you're set for life but man day in day
out to come up with all those new rules
bill maher who wants to do what to live
like
i mean he's not trying that hard anymore
picking that low-hanging fruit as he
makes msnbc host laugh at him feet away
from him oh god anyway uh no uh matt i
want to ask you so do you think in
multiverse of madness we might see a
watcher for him as like a dark doctor
strange a strange supreme and he would
be like the watcher of that multiverse
of madness event that's what i'm
thinking especially after you know uh
since this is canonical what if it's
it's canon in the mcu uh and we're
dealing with multiverse stuff in
multiverse of madness you know i'm
starting to think more and more that
this is actually going to heavily impact
that film and i think that's the way
it's going to go i think that you know
it's it's he's going to our doctor
stephen strange is going to have to
confront that stephen strange in some
sort of
crazy safe
saving the multiverse kind of deal uh
which will end with i think uh our
stephen strange uh will save ultimately
save uh the stephen strange has gone
corrupt do you think they're gonna leave
like strange supreme as animated and
it'll be like who framed roger rabbit
where you have like oh fun better to
cover match 3d versus 2d benedict
cumberbatch what i think is that uatu
the watcher just sees everything in
animated form like that's like his rose
tinted glasses that he sees the
multiverse in so at the end of it we
might see live action jeffrey wright who
just like blinks and now he's back in
live action and it just like helps them
digest these complex dark stories just
to see it animated
and that's that will just be the
rationale of it and we're actually in
westworld and he's just uh android and
yeah and doesn't look like anything to
me i mean can we just acknowledge real
quick that jeffrey wright is in
everything he's gonna be playing gordon
in the batman he was uh in westworld he
was in the hunger games like this guy
can do no wrong he already is watching
the watcher he's in every possible
fictional reality i'm watching it all
baby i think the watcher could be the
the big band that's a that's a great
theory man um i also i mean this first
un villain thing that we saw the
tentacled monster that they we've seen
in two different ones now and they won't
give us like a full shot of what it is
and then there's all these rumors of
like schumachuras showing up in you know
multiverse of madness it's like if this
tentacle monster isn't schuma gorath
then why haven't they shown it to us why
are they hiding it why adjust the
tentacles uh there's gotta be right to
it i think that could be the big bad but
i'm also i'm concerned about there's
been shots in the teaser of gamora right
kind of wearing thanos's armor yeah and
we know
we know from episode two that that
thanos gave up his his like jab uh his
his quest but maybe his daughter gamora
took it up and she's gonna out there to
finish the job and that's why these guys
are gonna have to come back together uh
to kind of stop this this gora this
gamora who gets the infinity stones and
maybe she's aware of the multiverse and
she's gonna use those infinity stones to
like cross the multiverse and really do
some damage maybe get her family back
that she lost
uh from the
you know i i assumed this diagnosis that
gave up his quest still murdered her
family and then gave up and she's
probably like what the hell that was for
nothing
i want revenge i want my family back i'm
gonna take him from whatever multiverse
i can get uh and that might be the big
bad is gamora herself i love that idea
brandon you know what's interesting is
yeah we do see gamora in the trailer
footage wielding that that copter sword
but we also see vision suited up in like
an ultron type armor with the infinity
stones in his chest i wonder
as part of this big melee final battle
that all these heroes will be suited up
in some kind of villainous shell
whatever like hermit crabs stealing each
other's shells to fight each other i
assume that happens like i wonder if
that could be something the way it goes
down like some uh villain is uh becoming
this the hero of their own story gives
up their previous armor and then the
hero takes that and they fight each
other i mean it's all about toys right
that's the kind of toy right yeah
that's selling i mean that sells is that
vision even vision or is that ultron
getting his
final what i was doing i thought i was
thinking what brandon was thinking when
i watched it i was like oh god it's
ultron
yeah i mean that's kind of theory right
that like it is ultron's final form what
he wanted to create at the end of uh at
the end of age of ultron before helen's
show was like but i want to revisit like
ego like i thought we were done with ego
from that episode two scene but in the
trailer now we see him back in the dairy
queen powering up peter quill what do we
think is next for that i think i you
know if if this ego finds a peter quill
who didn't get the perspective of the
one we saw in the mcu you know he could
very easily just plunk that little
battery boy and plug him into a system
and you know wipe out a bunch of planets
in the universe and finish that job that
he wanted to do i think that's the most
dangerous part is that this peter
quill's not gonna be put up a fight at
all or be like hell yeah let's do it dad
my life sucks i'm mopping up uh i'm
mopping up soda spills uh at the same
dairy queen where you banged my mom in
the woods like i gotta get out of here
get me out of here
you paint my mom in the woods he's
working at the same dairy queen where
they banged in the woods he doesn't know
that right now
i just work at the dairy queen i love
that do celestials bang people's moms in
the woods i mean come on if they do does
it make a sound you bet it does
you bet it does it's my favorite dear
evan hansen lyric um
so like this black panther uh you know
killmonger episode
ended so open-ended and we know in
trailer footage we do see shuri and
pepper potts leading the dora melange
kicking ass like have have each of these
standalone episodes just been the first
act of like what is truly a big two-act
event and that they're all they're not
anthologies that the the watcher's gonna
be like no i need you i need you i need
you i need you fight them oh that sounds
really cool i would love for him to be
like everyone's a toy and i get to
choose where everyone goes my whole
theory for this was essentially that i
thought zombie thanos would eventually
get all the stones because they were
still stupid but they were still able
able capable of um doing their jobs and
using their powers and using any kind of
technology so if he collected all those
stones and he was a zombie
do you know what he could do with all of
that power as a zombie that's just like
i'm gonna open the world and i'm just
gonna take it over and i'm gonna do
whatever i want so if he did open up the
like
timeline or different multiverses or
whatever and just bounce planet to
planet he could destroy everything
instead of just doing the snap so i
assumed with that being said that
opening that he could open up a multi
not like essentially what we want from
the multiversal war but he could open
and like release all the zombies into
any kind of plane and what that means i
think while that's happening we have the
second story i don't think they're gonna
all come together and fight universally
i think we have what's happening in
wakanda on its own because i think eric
killmonger still has that mission of
like this is revenge for me i hate the
outside world for what they did to my
people how they oppress them and i hate
what you guys did by to my father so i'm
just here to make sure you guys fight
each other and i'm just the man out of
it so i think these fights are all going
to be happening in different times and
so i don't think ego is going to come
into play right now i think that's going
to be a second season thing because
that's such a higher tier of what's
going on it's like well now i'm gonna
take over the world or like the universe
so i think we're just getting prepared
for that but right now we're gonna have
a fight between all different people and
at the end we're gonna have to make up
this like really bad team of avengers
and by bad team of avengers i mean who
we have right now who our current heroes
are let's round out this uh lineup that
we think is gonna be there for the
whatever this multiversal avengers team
i think we're talking about gamora i
think we're talking about um captain
carter
strange supreme maybe maybe party thor
the fact that we haven't seen that
episode yet but it seems like he's with
them i think spider-man will be there
the head of scott lang i think would be
the head of this guy yeah right right i
give him a battle suit you know what i
mean that's the part that i really want
to see is i was hoping if thanos like
opened up all these different portals
people would fall into different
situations even if he destroyed the
world that he's in and then like
spider-man or any of the new avengers
would jump through and show up in the
multiverse and they're the ones that are
like uh i came from an existence where
zombie thanos is a thing um but
i
who knows who knows what's gonna happen
yeah who knows
i think doctor strange is going to play
a good character at the beginning but
ultimately he's going to be the bad guy
because why would he want to go back to
his timeline there's nothing there
doctor estranged or are doctor strange
dog doctors
i don't think he'd want to go back to
what cause like it's nothingness and he
probably would find a new christine and
be like i can redo myself i think we'll
definitely see t'challa star-lord come
back too especially after that line that
astral or ancestral plane t'challa said
to him where he's like you're gonna get
you know your comeuppance either from
you know your plane or my plane and i
think
you know we could have like the
killmonger who runs wakanda and maybe
took over that world who knows he could
get pulled into all this and then you
know uh t'challa star-lord's gonna show
up and really freak him out uh and take
him down yeah um all right so i think we
have some really good thoughts headed
into these final couple episodes of what
if uh i am going to award some points
now jessica you are gonna get a point
for uh your idea that zombie thanos
could be the nexus being that uh causes
a huge multiversal chaotic event so
you're getting a point uh brandon you're
gonna get uh two points for suggesting
that uh gamora could pick up where uh
her daddy thanos left off but also this
i that's reminding us of this
interesting line from the recent episode
of either on your plane or mine i think
that was a huge clue of where things are
headed matt i'm gonna give you uh a
point for your idea that uh doctor
strange evil doctor stranger dark doctor
strange supreme could be the next
watcher going this original sin
direction i think that's a cool idea uh
i'm also going to give you a point for
uh dr estrade because hell yeah i just
love that thanks man so
but it's still anyone's game uh as we
move on in this episode but first over
at newrockstarsmerch.com they have not
one but two sheng chi inspired shirt
designs uh there's the latest obsession
shirt the great protector it's got a
cool dragon design there's also a new
shirt with that lovable uh fluff ball
morris both are in limited supply you
got to snap them up quick uh get
yourself a cool shirt help support new
rock stars and all the content we make
you can also get this uh what if shirt
getting the what if shirt the great
protector shirt allows you to write in
those custom shout outs in our uh inside
marvel episodes but with fall upon us
it's now a great time to grab a new
rockstars hoodie or a hat start plotting
that christmas list around some other
cool gear like a new rockstars bomber
jacket or a king shart backpack i said
king shark backpack
sure
you can't get that on the merch store
yet but we're working on that crossover
there's just a lot of cool stuff that
you can get that you won't find anywhere
else new rockstarsmerch.com hey
we want to thank our sponsor this
episode mint mobile after years of fine
print contracts and getting ripped off
by big wireless providers we've learned
that there's always a catch so when we
heard that mint mobile offers premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month we wondered what is that
catch going to be
well the catch is
there ain't one they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only they cut out the overhead costs and
pass on those sweet savings directly to
you and new rockstars philip reportedly
switched to met mobile and he reportedly
loves it i say reportedly because i i
don't know how he feels he's a
machiavellian uh but he got to keep his
phone and his number and he is saving so
much money for people looking for extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network and if
you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile has
you covered with their seven day money
back guarantee just switch to mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mobile.com rogue
theory that's mint mobile dot com slash
rogue theory cut your wireless bill to
15 bucks a month at mittmobile.com
all right uh one of the big questions i
had very early on watching episode six
of what if what's the fact that the
reason killmonger was in the kunar
province of afghanistan was he said he
was on some undercover mission with the
ten rings and they come out and say it i
love that they did this in the beginning
episode because now that we've all seen
chongqi we're like yes i know what that
is now and i have a sense of what was
going on with that organization around
that time just to remind you around 2008
that's right when win woo kind of
reactivated uh after all the stuff
happened with his wife uh so he
basically was like all right i'm john
wicking this [ __ ] now and he uh put the
rings back on he started rebuilding his
empire so now it seems like the tin
rings organization might have appeared
on more radars thus why killmonger has
joined them no word on why he wouldn't
be joining them in the um live action
universe it's what if it's a different
universe don't think too hard about it
but i want to ask you guys what do you
think his secret undercover mission with
the 10 rings was i was a little confused
so is it was he with the 10 ring like
the one whoosh 10 rings or because i
remember in iron man wasn't the the
terrorist organization also the ten
rings yes so that much has been cleared
it is the same organization but they got
like local chapters it sounds like yeah
but it's also not clear if raza might
have been appropriating the ten rings
iconography the way that the mandarin
and aldrich killian did mandarin being
trevor slattery mandarin uh because they
did have different logos but it seems
like raza was a true believer he seemed
like he was the guy who was drinking the
kool-aid of whatever the organization
was the similar
air bozonero speech
asian conquest etc etc so i like to
think that raza was working uh from
marching orders coming from central
command also you said john wicken like a
verb but it sounds like john wicken as
in he's a witch like
john the wicked that would be a badass
movie
yeah only with keanu reeves yeah so what
was his undercover mission was uh how
deep in was killmonger was he trying was
he just infiltrating the afghanistan uh
branch of it was he trying to find where
win woo was in asia i have a pretty
crazy rogue theory for you i did a
little research on this one okay so
these are these events of iron man all
right they're taking place around 2008
okay
we have the press conference after tony
has been saved by killmonger and our our
our faithful reporter of the mcu
christine everhart she points out hey
you were 400 clicks so your your unit
was 400 clicks away right which if you
look it up that's about 250 miles okay
kunar province it's right on the border
of afghanistan and pakistan okay in 2008
ben benazir budo was assassinated in
pakistan uh specifically in rawaldi i
may be saying that wrong which is near
islamabad okay
it's about 250 miles away from kunar all
right so i think here's what i think
uh uh killmonger was still working for
the government he was in the military
right and they had him embedded in the
ten rings uh and his group was tasked
with taking out benazir budo who used to
be a prime minister in pakistan uh and
he would he was not prime minister at
the time but he was leader of the
opposition party which was called the
pakistan people's party okay and so the
government you know our government does
not always do good things in other other
countries they had killmonger and his
unit there to infiltrate the ten rings
to make sure that they take out benazir
budo but during all of this killmonger
finds out about this other plan the ten
rings has and sneaks away from his unit
to go save tony stark and set his own
plan in motion but i think
that killmonger also killed benazir budo
that is my my rogue theory that's what
he was up to my god
i'm so mad so i mean come on
i'm not gonna say my story because it
really it really bugged me that
christine pointed out that the unit was
400 clicks away he was not with his unit
at the time so what were they up to
that's what got me thinking about it i
think you have a good point that could
have been what they were i didn't say
the direction they didn't say the
direction
but i think you do bring up a good point
uh that i think that went over a lot of
people's heads
really killmonger knew where tony stark
was gonna be he wanted to be there to
save tony stark so that he could get his
hands on its tech and use it to reclaim
wakanda i think that was his kind of his
plan throughout from the beginning
luckily that he was able to convince a
drunk tony stark to make him ceo of the
company as opposed to a guy who just
always thought he was about to drink it
for at the bar i mean i'm i'm i look i
didn't have the in-depth detail that you
did brandon
but mine was like along the lines of
that as well like he he was you know
like on some sort of mission but got
just got wind of it because he this is
like a ten year plan that that
killmonger is doing he's like you know
trying to sleep in so i kind of think at
first it was like him trying to sleep in
maybe into the ten rings for his own
reasons to like maybe get them to aid in
causing war against you know america and
who and wakanda right but he saw this
juicy opportunity this iron opportunity
to go and
save tony stark and
you go down that path instead but man i
gotta say that was just a really good
one uh but yeah that's that's kind of i
mean i i think similarly he was just
trying to do his own thing but uh
yeah i think it was just an easier plan
was to use tony stark instead what do
you think jess
i hate brandon that was a great one that
was a great damn theory i'm so mad you
should have gone last why did you go
last brandon
i dare you i dare you i was literally
gonna i guess like the same as matt i
was just like i think it's the one thing
that stuck to me was i was like even
though killmonger is actually really
smart and intelligent i think it's still
along the lines of they were probably he
was undercover probably doing something
that's still aligned with what tony
stark was doing because why else would
he be looking into the files of tony
stark if he wasn't already working on
like a tony stark mission so i think um
i thought he was just like they were
trying to steal like
war machine or rebuild something of tony
starks and then they found out like oh
you guys are getting all your money from
tony stark's ceo
that's weird i'm going to release all
these documents so that was truly mine
not as cool as that not as rogue and not
as cool it was really cool i do like the
idea of of thinking that maybe he you
know he was he is a killer and he is
very good so maybe he was actually
enlisted by one who himself and like you
know like was raised upon the actual ten
rings and maybe the the phrase blood
blood debt has to be played with blood
right maybe that like that that was like
the thing that really kicked into gear i
don't think so but i like to think of
like oh maybe they had like a little
exchange maybe uh
they had a little little conversation
over some you know good chinese i just
killmonger has too much confidence and
that his plans it did go exactly as
planned but i was like there could have
been an easy
up in this and it was making me so mad
that it was so flawless for you yeah so
that's why i'm like
you could be he also constantly mumbles
under his breath that he's like doing
the opposite you know he's like very
ballsy in that respect two times in the
episode he straight up was like
yeah the people were like he's a piece
[ __ ] and he's like i am a piece of [ __ ]
yeah because i found this and i was like
will you stop
i'm gonna punch you i'm gonna punch you
in your face i like how i do i do wanna
say i want i like how facially
mischievous this killmonger is like
every time he does something bad he's
like oh yeah uh you know what kind of
forever smirk to the camera
yeah yeah he smokes all the time in this
forever the government let him put
killmonger on his outfit yeah
what's
uh i'm so i'm also so tired
of the colonel just being like yeah no
he's an american hero he's a navy seal
he's never going to betray us i'm like
his name is killmonger you let him kill
my girlfriend he scars himself which i
know that's a ritualistic thing but this
guy is like he's hiding it under his
so
shirt
like
feels a little bad about it
he's a little self-conscious it was it
was a a while to hear thunderbolt ross
like bring up the patriot patriot act
huh like to take over a business that's
some heavy stuff man
it was also crazy because i think i
think you're right about wenwoo uh you
know this could be like they had him
infiltrating the the ten rings because
like when wu was like coming back to
power and like the government was like
something's going on with this terrorist
organization they've been quiet now
they're now they're moving again and
they're getting things done so it could
have been that like the government
wanted him to get close to when woo or
close to whatever the head of this
organization that is so mysteriously
powerful see i think i think the ten
rings would be killmonger's next target
like i think he he rose high enough i
think he's aware of what's going on
there now with the forces of wakanda
under his thumb he can go
go east and go sack whatever when woo
has built because his goal is not
wakanda his goal is global domination
and global liberation tear everything
down you know
everything well i guess when those
people have i guess it would kind of
align right i think win woo is just all
about conquest right yeah he was about
getting power he wanted i think he wants
to steal what win woo has he wants to
take his empire and then just kind of
unite the globe under his rule under his
vision but i i agree with what you guys
are saying i think that's kind of been
an issue i've always had with killmonger
as ways portrayed in the mcu is like
yeah he's cool i love the choices
michael b jordan has made with the
character a lot of the stuff ryan
coogler wrote for the character but it's
just like so easy for him to do what he
does
yeah yeah and like there is kind of like
a joker quality like dark knight joker
where he just kind of shows up and he's
got some cool plan like that london
museum plan was pretty fun but like you
we saw him struggle we saw what his loss
was but then after that like i'm glad
that he lost in black panther because
it's like yes there's no way he'd be
able to maintain rules over what god did
this is like a millennia old kingdom
like surely someone would have tried to
steal the throne in the past but in this
episode it's kind of hard to watch where
it's like everyone else seems so stupid
like t'chaka seems so stupid like the
fact that yes they all questioned the
beginning but the chuck is like no i
feel kind of bad yeah my son didn't just
die and i'm gonna give him his legacy to
this man that just showed up out of
nowhere and he he knew that he left he
left
eric behind right yeah he like chose to
leave him behind right yeah so whatever
it's it's what if it's what's
at the end of what if i think we needed
that part where it's like he went into
the world thinking he probably was gonna
see his dad instead it was t'challa
being like are you happy with what you
did where's
since i was eight and it's like yeah
well you got me instead
surprised [ __ ] the man you
killed yeah surprise
the guy you killed two days ago
your cousin
none of those other panthers are coming
out of the trees
you gotta stay up there you all stay up
there stay up in your trees don't you
come down also he went to straight he
went straight to the tree he didn't go
to the apartment
oh yeah that's what happened
his first fault you should have went
back to your childhood home when your
dad died what are you talking about
guys this is too much brandon obviously
you get a point for doing some research
now that was an incredible theory
jessica i'm also giving you a point
about that you talked to t'challa not in
jeopardy that doesn't make any sense i
was so good i was like god damn that's a
ruthless he just like i was like you
killed me you don't get to talk to your
dad now
all right we gotta move on to rogue
questions um so here is our question the
recently revealed hawkeye trailer teased
us a fully staged broadway musical
called rogers based on the life of
captain america so i want you to pitch
me one scene
or musical number in this musical um
sung by the characters involved bonus
points if you can sing me a lyric from
the musical
that's a good one this is a good one
okay well i think i think if this is a
musical about steve rogers so you're
gonna have at some point you have to
deal with bucky you know we didn't see
any any any bucky in the the one little
clip we got i hope the whole first
episode is just the this musical that's
all i want to see um but i think you're
gonna have the scene where bucky falls
off uh the the train and he loses bucky
uh and then bucky comes back in the
second act uh for the reprise but the
song that they're gonna have is gonna be
titled brothers in arms
uh because you know bucky loses his arm
classic classic stuff
a lyric from the song will be like i'll
never let you go
you'll always be my bro
[Music]
yeah
and then all the tracksuit russians and
the audience will go bro bro
bro i think the intro number will come
in
and it's gonna be skinny little rogers
at a little desk and he's just singing
like when i grow up
i'm gonna be a soldier when i'm older
i'm gonna be big and
he's thinking about it and then
immediately the lights turn on and
there's these buff soldiers that are
like you're too skinny too small get it
out you're never gonna fight in the war
you're gonna die at a computer and a
computer he's like what what computer
he's gonna work on the computers and i
don't know what time we're talking about
the community
so they're gonna be doing that and then
they're gonna be like there's gonna be
there has to be like that scene where
there's different voices of men and
they're going to be like your team is
scrawny there's going to be that one
that
he's just like
he's like you're too scrawny push him
into the big guy and he's like you're
too short throw him up into the air and
he's going to be like you're too
asthmatic
and it's like um it's the intro of him
getting bullied and then he he goes whoa
and spins into peggy carter's arms we're
not picking carter's well yeah he spins
into her arms and then she's just like
don't listen to them
you're gonna be a man someday
i don't know why it's always a man thing
but i don't know it you know
and then she spins them into the little
tube where he turns into the big ass man
it's a little jumpy it's a little jumpy
never said i was i love theater theater
didn't say i was a screenwriter for it
though so
that's great and then you can like call
it 4f that was his code for being uh oh
there you go but then it can go straight
jessica you you got to have him get buff
in the first song i think you need to
get it out of the way as quickly as
possible there's so much to fill
that's true there's too much i went to
town on this when i saw it so
a little bit about me i i like i was
back when hamilton like just came out i
did like a thing called hamilton's in la
and we did like sign up and like come
sing a song from hamilton so i got some
friends in there and when that came out
we just started talking immediately and
here are some of my favorites that we
came up with one of them i think one of
them is from thanos's perspective and
it's definitely played by jonathan groff
as you'll be snapped uh and it's it's
literally him singing about it's it's
him building up it's three times
throughout the show it's like we go up
to the you know it's it's we have three
acts in this play we have captain
america uh one they have the captain
battle of new york and then the third
act is like a mix of like windows winter
soldier uh and two like endgame right uh
but he has three times where he comes
out and saying you'll be snapped and
it's like yo it's it's jonathan graff
and he's and he's still he's kind of
it's like spoken word almost like like
you would be snapped soon you'll see
it's just literally you'll be back but
you'll be snapped and then there's the
battle of new york instead of the valley
yorktown right and it's just like we're
in it it's the first time they all come
together uh and it's and it's like it's
phil coulson is the one who says like
you have to avenge them you know i don't
know anyways
it's the whole thing i'm getting too
excited about this i love it like i eat
this [ __ ] up man and oh there could be
like your obedient servant but it's like
captain america and iron man uh right
because there's civil war it's like the
peak of civil war and like they're like
kind of talking [ __ ] to each other about
like the chords oh i love that can we
have a thanos uh lullaby where it's like
dear my gamora what to say to you
it's going to be yes it's it's thanos
singing gamora and then the do and then
the other one is tony stark singing to
uh um uh what's his what do you call his
daughter morgana we're gone
yeah there also has to be a scene that's
like r and b and sensual and it's when
he's listening to marvin gaye oh yeah
and we have to we just have to recognize
yeah and then ant-man sings uh what i
miss because uh he
oh that's perfect that is perfect i am
going to uh matt it sounds like you have
thought this through quite a bit you
will get a point for all your thinking
there um jess it sounds like you had the
most narrative figured out like you kind
of painted the clearest picture of what
that opening number will be so i got to
give you a point on this one i think all
three of you guys deserve the win on
this one all three of you had some
amazing theories
i have missed your theory so much and he
delivered you delivered at the end there
i gotta say none of you phoned it in i'm
so proud of all of you uh for really
committing hard to that final question
not an easy one some might bulk at it
not you three nine number well that is
it for this episode of rogue theory i
want to thank all of our guests jessica
clements matt essento oscar and producer
brandon barrack and you can support this
channel by checking out our latest
obsession shirt by shang chi and our
brand new shirt uh by that chicken pig
morris and our what if shirt as well
follow all three of these amazing people
on social media support all their other
projects that they're working on show
them some love online uh and
if you want to get some merch new
rockstarsmerch.com is where you can find
it you can follow me at ea boss follow
me rockstars on all social platforms and
be sure to subscribe of course to our
channel here on youtube i will see you
next time thanks everybody
bye
[Music]
you